yesterday morning at 7 00 am i woke up
to the sound of air raid sirens
um
and the announcement on loudspeakers
that bombing might commence soon and to
find shelter and to help the elderly and
the young find children as well so we
headed to the train station um we waited
in line an hour for the train
um
and
there was no training uh next train was
march 1st
then we headed to the bus station uh
next bus was february 28th and then we
just sort of set out on foot west
um because we considered that to be our
only option and then our first time in
trouble was that we started hitting gas
stations with no gas and tunnel cars
parked outside
uh because people had been fleeing from
the east all day long but all these cars
were along the road and the occupants of
these cars had left and were carrying
all their possessions with them at the
time and this included women and
children elderly people
they were carrying tons of luggage
and it was really tragic because you
could see these elderly people moving
very slowly these children moved very
slowly
and everybody had the goal of
getting to
safety getting to nato as quickly as
possible
and then we
started encountering soldiers ukrainian
army soldiers when we got even closer to
the border
and um
they
immediately started saying on
loudspeakers that zielinski president
zelinski of ukraine had just declared
that all men aged 18 to 60 had to be
conscripted by ukraine now and sent east
uh and this was to most of the men
around us a terrifying announcement
because most of the men were taking care
of families because the military was
ordering them at gunpoint to be
conscripted into the army now
and so a lot of them argue a lot of them
said look i have kids please don't make
me do this the military didn't care the
military pretty
violently and grassley
shoved these men out of their wives arms
and so there were a lot of heartfelt
emotional devise there were a lot of
kids who cried a lot and it was like a
desperation on the part of the ukrainian
citizens because
not only did they want to get through
that gate because they wanted to get
through that gate because they wanted to
get out of ukraine but because we were
out in the
time there was no sense of
electricity
internet toiletries toilets
food or water for anybody the world
needs to be aware of the humanitarian
crisis that's happening in ukraine right
now as we speak there are hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians at the border
suffering exactly what they subscribe to
you and i know that because i was doing
it last night
they're out in the cold they have no
food no water
no toilet and they're out there in the
cold for
20 30 hours sometimes maybe even more if
their borders got more crowded
it's a humanitarian crisis it's a
disaster